[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصادي الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياط في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتطور اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
الصوره الاولى من الخرطوم الاشتباكات
المستمره والمخاوف تتركز حول مصنع للاسلحه
جنوبي العاصمه مع حرائق كثيفه مع اقتراب
المواجهات من المستودعات الرئيسيه للغاز
والوقود
ثم الى كييف وتصريح لافت من امين مجلس
الامن القومي والدفاع الاوكراني يقول فيه
ان بلاده لم تشن بعد الهجوم المضاد المخطط
له
ثم الى العاصمه الروسيه موسكو لاوكرانيا
بتفجير خط انابيب
وهو اطول خط انابيب في العالم
ثم الى الولايات المتحده وتحديدا نيويورك
وهذا المشهد لضباب يلف المدينه بسبب
الحرائق المندلعه في مناطق بكندا ضباب
تسبب في الغاء عشرات من رحلات الطيران
ومخاوف من تلوث للهواء
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد تدمير سدك كيف تقول ان موسكو تسببت في
واحده من اسوا الكوارث البيئيه وروسيا
تقول ان تخريب اوكرانيا للسد متعمد لاغراض
عسكريه الجزيره ترصد الصوره منخرسون وسط
مخاوف من تداعيات بعيده المدى واردوغان
يدعو في اتصال مع بوتيم وزيلينسكي لتشكيل
اللجنه تحقيق دوليه
وسط معارك بالطائرات والمدفعيه واشتباكات
على الارض بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع حريق ضخم في محيط قاعده عسكريه
ومخازن وقود جنوبي الخرطوم وعقد مباحثات
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي في الرياض واشنطن
تقول ان بلينكن ونظره سعودي تعهد بمواصله
تعاونهما لانهاء القتال في السودان
على وقع توترات وخلافات مفتوحه بشان قضايا
امنيه وتجاريه ترتيبات لزياره وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي الى الصين الشهر الحالي
واشنطن تدعو بيجين للعوده الى قنوات
الاتصال العسكريه والصين تطالبها باحترام
مصالحها لعوده العلاقات الثنائيه الى
مسارها واختتام مرحله ثانيه من دوريات
جويه روسيه صينيه اثار توترا اقليميه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد وكما جرت
العاده ناقشنا معكم ابرز التداعيات
المحتمله للتدمير الجزئي الذي تعرض له سد
كفوفكا الاستراتيجيه جنوبي اوكرانيا
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم
بالتداعيات المحتمله للتدمير الجزئي لسد
كخوفكا جنوبي اوكرانيا وجاءت الاجابات على
النحو التالي
60% راوا ان الاثار الانسانيه والبيئيه هي
ابرز تداعيات تفجير السد اما نحو 40%
فاعتبروا ان التاثير الابرز سيكون على
جبهات القتال
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصتنا الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
ولقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
تطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
من كندا الى الولايات المتحده الغاء رحلات
طيران في نيويورك واكثر من 50 مليون شخص
معرضون للهواء الملوث
[موسيقى]
انها كارثه من قبل كنا نعرف اين تكمن
المخاطر اما اليوم فلم نعد نعرف هذا ما
قاله المتحدث بسم اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر محذرا من تداعيات كارثيه لتدمير
سدك خوفكا في جنوب اوكرانيا مراسل الجزيره
فيخرسون قال ان القوات الاوكرانيه تمكنت
من اجلاء 1500 شخص من مدينه خرسون عاقبه
تفجير سد كخوفكا نوفاكا خوفكا وقد رصد
مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود من شوارع خيرسون
الاثار الناجمه عن تفجير سد نوفا
لا يعبرون النهر انما شوارع مدينتهم خرسون
الغارقه بالمياه بعد تفجير سد كخوفكا
ومحطته الكهرومائيه الواقعه على نهر
دينيبرو بين ضفتيه هذه الزوارق فقط باتت
الوسيله الوحيده للتحرك بعدما ارتفع مستوى
المياه الى اكثر من اربعه امتار وغمرت
الاف المنازل تطوع اندريه وصديقه كالمئات
غيرهم للبحث عن ناجين رغم كونهما ايضا من
المتضررين
حتى اللحظه اجليته اكثر من 30 شخصا بقارب
الصغير هذا انه وضع غير معقول انها كارثه
الالاف تم اجلاؤهم لكن البحث عن المزيد
متواصل
مسابقه
تحاول فرق الانقاذ اجلاء المزيد من السكان
لقد غامرت المياه 29 بلده بشكل كامل في
خرسون 10 منها في الاراضي المحتله
مؤقته
حجم الكارثه طال كل كائن حي في هذه
المدينه في احلك الظروف يصل هؤلاء الى بر
غير امن تماما فالحدث الذي وصفته الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه باكبر كارثه انسانيه من صنع
البشر منذ عقود ليس طبيعيا بل نتيجه تفجير
متعمد تتهم اوكرانيا روسيا بتنفيذه لتعطيل
عمليات استعاده الضفه اليسرى من النهر
بينما ينفي الروس هذه الروايه ومن هناك
وصل
بعدما وحدت الكارثه حال الضفتين
المتقاتلتين
خلال هذين اليومين لم نر لها مثيلا اتيت
عبر النهر ورايت جنود الروسي يفرلون من
مواقعهم ووصلت الى هنا مع عائلتي بعد عناء
وسط مخاطره كبيره اجدي اكثر من 1500 شخص
من 80 بلده غارقه في اليوم الاول فقط على
التفجير عبر مياه تحركت داخلها الالغام
التي كانت مزروعه على طول جبهه النهر ما
شكل حاله معقده بات السكان اكبر ضحاياها
لطالما قال الاوكرانيون انه منتظروا طويلا
كي تجف هذه الارض فيبدا هجومهم المضاد لكن
تفجير السد اغرقها هذه المره
قد يكون الماء اطفئ نار الجبهه هنا مؤقتا
لكن رياحها قد تهب في جبهه اخرى مستغله
هذا الظرف او قد تشتعل هنا مجددا بعد
انحسارها انما بواقع ميداني مختلف حسن
مسعود الجزيره
كان هذا في الجانب الاوكراني اما في مناطق
السيطره الروسيه ففرضت السلطات الروسيه في
منطقه خرسون جنوبي اوكرانيا حاله الطوارئ
بسبب ارتفاع منسوب المياه كما اعلنت سلطات
خرسون المواليه لروسيا غرق نحو الفين
وسبعمائه منزل واجلاء 1300 شخص من المناطق
التي غمرتها المياه
هذا وقد اجرى الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان اتصالين هاتفيين مع نظريه
الاوكراني والروسي وفي اتصاله مع الرئيس
الاوكراني دعا اردوغان الى تشكيل لجنه
تحقيق دوليه بشان تفجير سد نوفا
وقد قال زيلينسكي انه تحدث مع اردوغان عما
وصفه بالعواقب الانسانيه
والبيئيه للعمل الارهابي الروسي في
محطتكوفكا للطاقه الكهرومائيه بما في ذلك
المخاطر التي تتعرض لها محطه
حسب تعبيره من جانب اخر قال الكريم ان
الرئيس الروسي ابلغ نظيره التركي خلال
الاتصال ان تفجير كياب محطه كفوفكا
الكهرومائيه جاء بتحريض من الغرب واصفا
اياه بالعمل الهمجي حسب تعبيره
معنى من موسكو اندريوف نائب وزير الخارجيه
الروسي السابق ومن كييف الكسندر ميرجيكو
رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان
الاوكراني اهلا بضيفيه الكريمه نبدا بضيف
من موسكو السيد لاساله عن هذه المبادره من
الجانب التركي وامكانيه القبول على الاقل
من الجانب الروسي
بلجنه دوليه تبحث عن من يقف خلف تفجير سد
كفوفكا في ظل تنصر الطرفين من المسؤوليه
سؤال مهم لانه من سيقوم بتشكيل هذه اللجنه
لجنه التحقيق هذه القضيه الاولى القضيه
الثانيه ما الذي سيتم التحقيقه حوله لانه
هنالك
غيابي اغلبيه وتدمير
مصنع انتاج الطاقه والمشكله الاكبر ايضا
كيف بامكان التواصل الاتفاق على هذه
القضيه بين روسيا واوكرانيا كل هذه امور
صعبه التحقيق ايضا ضيفي من لم نسمع قبولا
او رفضا من الجانب الاوكراني لهذا المقترح
التركي وبالتالي ما فرص ان يتم القبول
بلجنه دوليه للاجابه على السؤال من يقف
خلف تفجير
سد كخوفكا
ضد اوكرانيا ومن ضمنها هذه الجريمه ايضا
ابقى معك
ذلك ترجح بان كيف ليس لديها مانع في وجود
لجنه دوليه
انا لا استطيع التحدث نيابه عن حكومتنا
لانني لا امثل جهه رسميه بعينها انا اتحدث
من جهه وجهتي نظر شخصيه كعضو في البرلمان
وكاستاذ في القانون الدولي وكما قلت اننا
لا نخشى اي تحقيق عند وديه في مصلحتنا في
حقيقه الامر ان يتم التوصل الى الحقيقه
ومحاسبه بوتين وكل المجرمي الحرب المحيطين
بهم
سيدروف لماذا قد تلجا اوكرانيا الى تفجير
هذا السد اذا كانت موسكو ترى ذلك وتتهم
اوكرانيا بفعل ذلك
من وجهه نظري موسكو الرسميه كان هذا
الساده تم الاضرار به وتدميره عن عمدا من
قبل الجانب الاوكراني من اجل عادي اي
امكانيه للقوات الروسيه في ان تقوم بشن
هجمات من تلك المنطقه باتجاه خرسون
المشكله هي ان الضرر الذي لحق بروسيا بسبب
تدبير هذا السد هو اكبر من الضرر الذي
الحق باوكرانيا لان
روسيا تسيطر على
الجانب
الشرقي وقد دمر بالكامل تقريبا من الواضح
هي تماما انه اي تحقيق نت بالتاكيد اي
تحقيق الموضوعي هنالك حاجه اليه كما اتذكر
كما قال الرئيس فان كييف ليس لديها اي
ادله قاط عه على ان هذا العمل كانت وراءه
روسيا ويجب ان يكون هنالك تحقيق
في تفجير هذا السد بحسب ما تتهموا كيف بها
بدايه ان اوكرانيا
قامت بالتوجه الى المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه وتعظبت منها التحقيق هذه جريمه
حرب ارتكبتها روسيا من المستحيل على
اوكرانيا ان تقوم بتفجير هذا السد انه كان
تحت السيطره الروسيه كان هنالك ايضا مناجم
كان هنالك من مناجم تفصل عفوا
الغاب تفصل الحقول الغام تفصل الجانب
الاوكراني هذا امر واضح لان روسيا هي
خائفه وقلقه من الهجمه الاوكرانيه المضاده
هذه حركه يائسه من الجانب الروسي من اجل
ان توقف الهجمه المرتده
لكنني استطيع ان اؤكد ان روسيا ست هزم وان
بوتين سيتم محاكمته كمجرم حرب
اذا كانت موسكو ترى بان كياب هي من قامت
بهذا العمل وبالتالي
ما الاثار المترتبه عن تفجير هذا السد
وتؤثر على الجانب الروسي
بدايه بالتاكيد فان
هنالك
صوره
وعواقب سياسيه واضحه اذ انه يتم التوجيه
التعب الى روسيا وروسيا الان تحاولوا
وتدافع عن نفسها ايضا هنالك ضرر اقتصادي
كبير لحق بالمناطق التي تسيطر عليها روسيا
والنقطه الثالثه اقول ان هذا الامر سيؤثر
بطريقه او باخرى على النشاطات العسكريه في
المنطقه وعلى جبهات القتال بشكل عام ايضا
نفس الزاويه ضيفي من كياب السيده الكسندر
ايضا ما حجم الضرر الذي يحدث او يقع على
الجانب الاوكراني اذا كانت موسكو هي من
قامت بهذا العمل ماذا تريد من ذلك
برنامج
الذي تم
احداثه هنالك ضرر بيئي وهنالك الالاف من
السكان الذين فقدوا منازلهم وغرقت لدينا
ايضا فيضانات والنتائج
بها خلال العقود القادمه ما الذي تحاول
موسكو ان تحققه امر واضح اباده جماعيه
موسكو تحاول ان تقضي على كل الاوكرانيين
لكي تقوم بتدمير دولتنا ومحينا من الخريطه
العالم هذا امر واضح هذه حرب اباده
حرب استعماريه ضد الشعب الاوكراني روسيا
دائما قامت باستهدافي الاهداف المدنيه
عمدا روسيا تم الاعتراف بها على انها نظام
ارهابي من قبل عدد من المنظمات الدوليه
ولا يمكن ان نثقب روسيا على الاطلاق
رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان
الاوكراني شكرا لك وكذلك لضيفي من موسكو
اندري نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي السابق
عدد من المنشات الحيويه كانت ضمن بنك
الاهداف لكل من روسيا وكذلك اوكرانيا منذ
بدء هذه الحرب لم يقتصر ضربها على حيز
جغرافي معين بل اتسع نطاق ذلك حتى في عرض
بحر البلطيخ كما حدث مع خط انابيب نور
ستريم نستعرض ابرز هذه المنشات المستهدفه
في التقرير التالي
طيله مسار حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا منشات
مهمه واستراتيجيه كانت عرضه للاستهداف
والقصف في شرق اوكرانيا وجنوبها وايضا قرب
شبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها روسيا وحتى في
بحر البلطيق كانت معركه ازوف ستال في
ابريل من العام الماضي حاسمه للطرفين فهي
على اراضي مصنع ازوستاد للمعادن الذي دمر
بالكامل وهو من اكبر مصانع التعليم في
قاره اوروبا وفتحت الباب للسيطره الروسيه
على ماريوبول في صباح الثامن من اكتوبر من
العام الماضي هزا انفجار جسر القرم الذي
يربط شبه جزيره القرم بمنطقه كوبان
الواقعه في الجنوب الروسي واستخدم لتزويد
القوات الروسيه بالاسلحه خلال هجومها على
الجنوب الاوكراني واعتبرته اوكرانيا هدفا
عسكريا
محطه زابولوجيا النوويه بدورها من المرافق
المهمه التي استهدفت اكثر من مره في ظل
اتهامات متبادله بين الطرفين بشان قصف
منشات المحطه وسط مخاوف من خطر وقوع كارثه
تسرب في اكبر محطه نوويه في اوروبا خط
انابيب نور ستريم او السيد الشمالي استهدف
جزء منه بتفجير في سبتمبر من العام الماضي
وهو خط انابيب مزدوج يتجاوز طوله
الفينومتر وينقل الغاز مباشره من روسيا
الى المانيا عبر بحر البلطيق بينما نقلت
واشنطن بوست عن وثائق مسربه ان
الاستخبارات الامريكيه تعتقد ان قوات
اوكرانيه خططت للهجوم سد نوفاك خفق
العملاق في خرسون جنوبيه اوكرانيا على نهر
دنيبرو منشاه اخرى عرضه للاستهداف وسط
تبادل كييف وموسكو الاتهامات بشان تفجيره
وتقع بجانبه محطه كخوفكال الكهرومائيه وفي
الاتهامات المتبادله بين روسيا واوكرانيا
احدث الاستهدافات تفجير جزء من خط انابيب
لضخ الامونيا بمنطقه خركيف خط التولياتي
اوديسي الممتد لنحو
2470 كيلومترا توقف عن العمل منذ بدء
الحرب يكتسب اهميه حيويه لتمديد اتفاق
تصدير الحبوب والاسمده من موانئ البحر
الاسود
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات في السودان ونبدا بهذه الصور
المباشره من جنوبي العاصمه الخرطوم لحريق
ضخم بالقرب من محيط مصنع اليرموك للاسلحه
التابع لمنظومه الصناعات الدفاعيه
السودانيه وتثير هذه الاشتباكات الخوف من
اندلاء حرائق كبيره لقربها من خزانات وقود
كبيره
في السودان يعلو صوت السلاح ويخفض صوت
الحوار في محيط مصنع اليرموك للاسلحه
التابع لمنظومه الصناعات الدفاعيه
السودانيه تدور اشتباكات عنيفه استخدمت
فيها مختلف الاسلحه بالقرب من اكبر خزانات
الغاز والوقود في الخرطوم انفجار هذه
الخزانات يشكل خطرا على سكان المناطق
المجاوره شنت قوات الدعم السريع في وقت
سابق هجوما على المصنع فيما يبدو انها
محاوله للسيطره عليه لكنها تراجعت بعد ذلك
دون ان تتوقف المعارك تخوض قوات الدعم
السريع مواجهات مع قوات الجيش منذ ثمانيه
اسابيع وهي ليست قوات النظاميه لها مخزون
كبير من الذخائر ويعتقد ان بمصنع ديرمو
كميات كبيره من الاسلحه والذخائر ولذلك
فاستهدافه من الدعم السريع امر متوقع
منذ انتهاء الهدنه الاخيره السبت الماضي
خفت صوت الدبلوماسيه قال بيان لوزاره
الخارجه الامريكيه ان وري العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان ووزير الخارجي
الامريكي
تعهد خلال لقائهما في جده بمواصله تعاونهم
القوي لانهاء القتال في السودان واكدت
الحاجه الامريكيه ان الدبلوماسيه هي
الكفيله بحل الصراع وانه لا حل عسكريا
للازمه اما مجموعه اصدقاء السودان التي
تضم فرنسا والمانيا والنرويج والسويد الى
جانب السعودي والامارات والمملكه المتحده
والولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي فقد
عبلت عن قلقه العميق ازاء استمرار العنف
والوضع الانساني الكارثي في السودان وحثت
الاطراف المتحاربه على وقف القتال حتى
الان صوت السلاح هو الاعلى في السودان ومع
مرور الوقت في ظل هذا الوضع تتعمق ازمه
انسانيه تطول ملايين السودانيين تشير
تقديرات مشروع تحديد وتجميع بيانات
النزاعات المسلحه الى ان 10800 سوداني
قتلوا منذ بدايه النزاع في الخامس عشر من
ابريل الماضي وحسب منظمه الهجره الدوليه
اضطر نحو مليون ونصف مليون سوداني الى
الهرب من بيوتهم والنزوح داخل السودان
فيما لجا نحو نصف مليون سوداني الى دول
الجوار ويزداد الامر سوءا في اقليم دافور
الذي يشهد اسوا المعارك الى جانب الخرطوم
هناك تقول المنظمات الانسانيه ان المعارك
تعوق وصول ابسط المساعدات الانسانيه وحسب
الامم المتحده فان نحو 25 مليون سوداني اي
اكثر من نصف الشعب في حاجه الان الى
المساعده والحمايه
معنا من باريس محمد تورشين الكاتب والباحث
السياسي السوداني اهلا بك السيد محمد
تزداد
النيران في السودان الا اشتعالا وبالتالي
ماذا عن حظوظ الجهود الدبلوماسيه السياسيه
لتهدئه اولا ومن ثم محاوله ايجاد حل في ظل
هذه النيران المشتعله
في البدايه التحيه لك
المشاهدين الكرام
هل في ظل التراجع الجهود الامريكيه
السعوديه
جده او في منبرجات التفاوض وكذلك حتى الان
لم نلمس اي خطوه من المبادره الافريقيه
والاليه الافريقيه التي كانت نتائج
الاخيره الذي حدث لمجلس السينما والامن
الافريقي يبدو ان فرص وحصوص هذه المبادرات
المرتبطه بالتسويه هي محدوده جدا في ظله
ارتفاع وتيره المواجهات المسلحه
والتصعيد اليوم لا صيامه في محيط مصنع
اليرموك باعتباره مخزن
ومستودع مهم جدا للاسلحه والذخائر ويبدو
ان الدعم السريع كان يجعل السيطره عليه
حتى يتحصل على مخزون ضخمي من الاسلحه
والذخائر هذا يعكس لك بانه كل طرف يسعى
الى السيطره على مناطق يسعى الى الحصول
على
امداد حتى يستمر في هذه المعرفه الذي التي
نتوقع ان تستمر لفترات طويله للاسف الشديد
قلت اتراجع في الجهود الامريكيه رغم ان
اخر تصريحات الامريكيه عن جهود مره اخرى
امريكيه سعوديه بل عبد الله اوسع امريكيه
مع مجلس دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي من اجل
ايجاد حل الملف السوداني وبالتالي كيف
نفهم هذه الجهود الاخيره
محاولات حديثه من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والمملكه العربيه السعوديه منذ
لها الوهله الاولى لهذه المواجهات لكن انا
في تقدير هذه
المبادراتك وهذه المساعي تشوبها العديد من
العقبات والتحديات لاسيما في قضيه
تراجعوا انسحاب قوات الدعم السريع من
المنشات الحيويه وكذلك الاحياء
والمستشفيات باعتبار ان هذه الاليه او
المبادره السعوديه ليس لديها اليات كافيه
لضبط تحركات الاطراف اطراف الصراع على ارض
الواقع بحيث ان غالبا ما تعتمد على
التقارير التي تصدر من بعض الجهات التي
لديها مصالح بشكل او باخر مع احد طرفي
الصراحه فبالتالي انا في تقدير اذا لم
تتمكن المبادره او الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والسعوديه في ايجاد وسائل ناجعه
من خلال انها تحدد مسارات وكذلك النقاط
تجمع قوات الدعم السريع من
الوهله الاولى فمن الصعب جدا ان تحقق هذه
المباحثات وان تم اعلان هدنه او وقف دائم
لاطلاق النار لن تحقق شيء على ارض الواقع
لان لا يمكن للدعم السريعا ان في الاحياء
باعتبار ان كل المناطق التي كان
بمسافه مقرات له والان تم استهدافهم
ومواجهتها من قبل الطيران العسكري والجيش
السوداني
للاسف ادركنا الوقت السيد محمد واعتذر منك
محمد طورشين الكاتب والباحث السياسي
السوداني كنت معنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الوزير
انطوني بلينكن اجتمع مع نظيره السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان في الرياض حيث ناقش
مجموعه من القضايا الثنائيه والاقليميه
وكذلك العالميه وقال بيان الخارجيه ان
الجانبين تعهد بمواصله تعاونهما القوي
لانهاء القتال في السودان وقالت وكاله
الانباء السعوديه ان وزير الخارجيه
السعودي بحث مع نظيره الامريكي او وجوه
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين وسبل
تعزيز التعاون الثنائي في مختلف المجالات
هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بليكن في تغريده له ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تقدر الشراكه مع مجلس التعاون
الخارجي بما في ذلك العمل العاجل معا بشان
الوضع في السودان والسعي الى حل دائم
للصراع في اليمن ومواجهه سلوك ايران
المزعزع للاستقرار وفق تعبيره
هذا وتقرا رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن ال ثاني مع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انتوني بلينكن بمقر الامانه
العامه لمجلس التعاون في مدينه الرياض
بالسعوديه وذلك على هامش انعقاد الاجتماعي
الوزاري المشترك للشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين
دول مجلس التعاون لدول الخليج العربيه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه جرى خلال
اللقاء استعراض علاقات الصداقه والتعاون
الاستراتيجيه بين قطر والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وافاق تطويرها اضافه الى تبادل
وجهات النظر حيال ابرز القضايا الراغنه
الاقليميه والدوليه محل الاهتمام المشترك
معنا منا واشنطن
مدير التعاون الدولي السابق في البيت
الابيض خلال اداره الرئيس الاسبق باراك
اوباما اهلا بك عندما نتكلم عن شراكه
استراتيجيه بين الولايات المتحده وهذا
اللقاء الذي جمعها بدول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي ما الذي ميز هذا اللقاء في ظل
التحولات الراغنه في جمله ملفات والعلم من
ابرزها او من بعضها ما يتعلق بالشان
السوداني
ان بدايه ان السودان هي مثال جيد للتعاوني
في تعاون الوثيق الذي تجريه وتامل بتحقيقه
الولايات المتحده مع دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي لانه من الواضح ان هنالك زياده في
الضغوط هنالك حدود للضغط الذي تستطيع ان
تسلطه الولايات المتحده وعن طريق شركتها
مع دول الخليج باستطاعتها ان تقوم بالمزيد
من اجل تحقيق وتوصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار
واحلال السلام في السودان بالتالي بهذا
بطريقه من الطرق يكون هو ربما نموذج جيد
ويمكن لتطبيقه في اماكن وفي مواجهه تحديات
اخرى في المنطقه وتحديات عالميه
وهو مثال جيد للعلاقات الجديده التي
تمتلكها الولايات المتحده مع دول الخليج
بالاشاره الى ملف ايران الذي ورد في
تغريده وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه هناك تغير
حدث في الاشهر الماضيه وبالتالي ما الذي
قد يميز هذا اللقاء فيما يتعلق بهذا الملف
اعتقد ان هنالك
زياده في الخلافات واختلافات ويوجات النظر
بين الولايات المتحده ودول الخليج في حول
هذه القضيه لكن في نهايه المطاف هنالك
اتفاق ان ايران لا يجب ان تمتلك سلاحا
نوويا واعتقد ان جميع سيعمل نحو تحقيق هذا
الهدف في نهايه المطاف هنالك محاوله
للعوده الى نقطه حيث لا يكون هنالك
اي سلاح نووي في ايران الولايات المتحده
في بالتالي ستستمروا بالضغط على ايران من
اجل ان تقوم
بتقديم تنازلات وربما دول مثل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه التي فتحت حوارا مباشرا
مع ايران وايضا مع النموذج السوداني
وتطبيقه مع ايران ربما نرى ان فتح اواصر
والحوار الدبلوماسيه بين الرياض وايران
وايضا الغرب سيستمر وبالضغط
بنتائج لو اردنا ان نضع عنوانا لهذا
اللقاء بين الولايات المتحده ونظرائها من
مجلس التعاون الخليجي في حوار استراتيجي
ما اهم عنوان يوجد نضعه لهذا اللقاء
اعتقد انا ما استطاعتنا قولها ان دول
الخليج لديها
زياده في
اهميتها
هنالك مثلا
فصوله جديده ستشهدها المنطقه واشنطن هناك
لكي تحاول ان تتعاون مع دول المنطقه من
اجل مواجهه التحديات الاقليميه والعالميه
ايضا من واشنطن مدير التعاون الدولي
السابق في البيت الابيض خلال اداره الرئيس
الاسبق باراك اوباما شكرا جزيلا لك
قال الكريملين ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين اجرى محادثه هاتفيه مع ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان وافاد
الكريم بان بوتين وولي العهد السعودي ناقش
موضوع ضمان الاستقرار في سوق الطاقه
العالميه حيث ثمن الطرفان بشكل عال مستوى
التعاون في اطار منظمه اوبك بلاس للحفاظ
على التوازن بين العرض والطلب على النفط
واشار الكريم الى ان الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين والامير محمد بن سلمان اكد اهميه
الاتفاقات النفطيه التي تم التوصل اليها
في الاجتماع الوزاري في الرياض كما ناقش
زياده العلاقات التجاريه وتنفيذ المشاريع
في مجالات الاستثمار واللوجستيات والطاقه
[موسيقى]
الى ملف التوتر الصينيه الامريكي بالتزامن
مع مناوره جويه صينيه روسيه لافته في شرق
اسيا فقد قال مسؤولون امريكيون ان وزير
الخارجيه انتونيكنز سيتوجه الى الصين
لاجراء محادثات في الاسابيع المقبله من
اجل خفض التصعيد بين البلدين بينما دعا
السفير الامريكي في بيجيم دعا الصين
للعوده الى قنوات الاتصال العسكريه من
جانبها قالت الخارجيه الصينيه ان العلاقات
الصينيه الامريكيه تواجه حاليا تحديات لكن
المسؤوليه لا تقع على عاتق بلاده واضافت
ان على الجانب الامريكي احترام المصالح
الاساسيه لبيجين
مع تدهور علاقاتهما اكثر فاكثر بسبب
خلافات عالقه واخرى طارئه تجهد الولايات
المتحده والصين في انقاذ تلك العلاقات وفق
مبدا الحد من الضرر او خفض التصعيد على
الاقل اقوى المؤشرات على ذلك ما كشف عنه
مسؤولون امريكيون عن ان وزير الخارجيه
انتوني بلينكن يستعد لزياره بيجين خلال
الاسابيع المقبله لم يتحدد بعد تاريخ
الزياره لكنها ستكون على الارجح قبل نهايه
حزيران يونيو الجاري حيث من المرتقب وفق
المصادر الامريكيه ان يلتقي بلينكل كبار
المسؤولين الصينيين مع احتمال الاجتماع
ايضا مع الرئيس تشي جينغ بينج اما بيجين
فما فتات تعيد التذكره بمطالبها القديمه
تواجه العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه حاليا
تحديات لكن المسؤوليه لا تقع على عاتقنا
يجب على واش ان تحترم مصالحنا الاساسيه
ومخاوفنا الرئيسيه وان تتوقف عن التدخل في
شؤوننا الداخليه والاضرار بمصالحنا وانت
كف عن قول شيء وفعل شيء اخر علينا العمل
معا لدفع العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه الى
المسار الصحيح
ترى ان تمت بالفعل تكون قد تاجلت نحو خمسه
اشهر كامله فهو الغى زياره كانت مقرره
للصين في شباط فبراير الماضي بسبب حادثه
المنطاد الصيني الذي دخل المجال الجوي
الامريكي واسقطته واشنطن معتبره مياه من
طادا ذا اغراض تجسس عسكري لا يعرف ما اذا
كان مسار خفض التصعيد الصيني الامريكي
سيتوج قريبا او انه يحتاج لمزيد من الوقت
لكن المؤكد ان حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
لعبت دورا اساسيا في تدهور العلاقات بين
القوتين العالميتين لا سيما مع اتهام
واشنطن
بمحاوله مد موسكو بالاسلحه وعليه يبدو
لزاما على اي تقارب ان يمر من هذه البوابه
وفق التصور الامريكي
العلاقات بين الصين وروسيا اوكرانيا مثيره
للقلق نسعى مع حلفائنا الاوروبيين الى فرض
قيود على انشطه معينه تنموسين القيام بها
ونريد ان تلعب بجين دورا دبلوماسيا مسؤولا
بشان اوكرانيا
تنفي الصين دائما تلك الاتهامات لكنها
تتمسك بعلاقاتها الوثيقه مع روسيا
والاربعاء انهى البلدان ثاني مرحله من
الدوريات الجويه المشتركه فوق غرب المحيط
الهادئ في اعقاب دوريات فوق بحر اليابان
وبحر جنوب الصين مما اثارها لع حلفاء
الولايات المتحده في المنطقه خاصه اليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه
معنا من واشنطن برايان هاردينج مستشار
وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق لشؤون امن
اسيا والمحيط الهادي ومن بيجين فيكتور جاو
نائب رئيس مركز الصين والعلماء اهلا بكم
وابدا بضيف من واشنطن السيد برايان
هاردينج مع حظوظ ان يقوم فعلا وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي بزياره بيجين هذه
المره شاهدنا في الايام الماضيه في قمه
شانجريلا تصريحات تصعيديه وناريه من
الطرفين وبالتالي ما حظوظ ان يزور بيجين
هذه المره فعلا
بكل تاكيد نحن نتحدث عن لحظه اعتقد ان كلا
الطرفين فيها يودان ان يتاكد من فتح قنوات
اضافيه للتواصل والحوار ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تود ان تحافظ على هذه
القنوات بالرغم من التصعيد تبرز الحاجه
الى الحوار بين الطرفين لتفادي اي حوادث
او اي مواجهات غير مرغوب بها ولكن من جهه
اخرى شاهدنا كما اشرتم في حوار شانجريلا
منذ ايام
النبره التي كانت في تلك الفعاليه
وبالتالي يجب ان هناك
نعرف ان هناك تصعيد ولكن تبرز الحاجه بنفس
الوقت الى حوار مباشر ولكن بكل تاكيد
السيد بلينكن ينظر في امكانيه زياره بيجين
في القريب العاشر
ضيفي من بيجين في حال ما تمت هذه الزياره
كيف تنظر بيجيل لهذه الزياره لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
في البدايه اعتقد ان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي السيد بلينكن كان يجب ان يزور
بيجين في شهر شباط فبراير ولكن قام ولكنه
قام بتجاهل القرار الذي اتخذ على مستوى
رئاسي بين الرئيس شيجن بين الرئيس بايدن
وقرر ان لا ياتي ويزور الصين وبالتالي هو
يعاني من تبعاتي موقفه هو طبعا الصين ليس
موقفها انها لا تود ان تنخرط في حوار مع
نظرائها ومع السيد بلنكن على وجه الخصوص
ولكن المشكله هي ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا تتعامل مع الصين باحترام
وبطريقه من الند الى الند
واستمعنا الى مداخله الزميل وقد ذكر القمه
شنغري
اود ان اوضح في هذا السياق ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي من فرض العقوبات على
الصين والصين اصرت انه اذا ما اراد وزير
الدفاع اوستن ان يلتقي بينظيره الصيني
يتعين على الولايات المتحده ان ترفع
العقوبات المفروضه على وزير الدفاع الصيني
هذا منطقي وبالتالي يجب ان ترفع العقوبات
قبل ان يتم اللقاء والا السيد الوزير وزير
الدفاع اوستن لا يمكنه ان يتوقع ان يلتقي
بنظيره الصيني لذلك اعتقد
انقل ما ذكرته الان بالاضافه الى الشروط
الصينيه الموضوعه والمقدمه للجانب
الامريكي لاسال ضيفي من واشنطن السيد
هاردينج ما المنتظر ان تحققه هذه الزياره
للسيد بلانكم في ظل ما تشترطه الصين
في البدايه ما اشار اليه الدكتور
فيه عدم ذكر لكل التفاصيل على وهي ان هناك
منطادا صينيا حلق في الاجواء الامريكيه
وهو من طاده تجسس الصيني ولا نعرف ما اذا
كان هذا المنطاد وصل الى الاجواء
الامريكيه بتوجيهات وتعليمات مباشره من
الرئيس تشيجين ولكننا نعرف ان هذه العمليه
هي عمليه التجسسيه وقد تمت السيد لم يذكر
هذه النقطه ولكن النقطه الاساسيه هي ان
الحوار يجب ان يحصل المشكله في الصين هي
ان السلطه تتركز في اعلى الهرم على مستوى
الرئاسي وبالتالي من الصعوبه بمكان ان تتم
العمليات
اي فتح القنوات على مستويات اخرى عاده
يكون هناك عدد من المسؤولين على المستوى
الوزاري او على مستويات اخرى في الدوله
يمكنهم ان يتواصلوا في مبالهم ولكن
المشكله هي تركز السلطه في الصين وايضا
انقل ما ذكرته الان لضيفي من
حظوظ ان يكون هناك اختراق في هذه الزياره
المنتظره او المعلن عنها حتى الان من قبل
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
على المستوى الشخصي انا اعمل ان وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي السيد بلينكن سوف ياتي
في اقرب فرصه ممكنه ويزول الصين لاننا
نتحدث عن قوتين اساسيتين في العالم ويجب
ان تتخاطب وتتحدثا مع بعضهما البعض ولكن
من الندء الى الندل لا يمكن السيد بلنكن
ان يتوقع بان يدلي بتصريحات ضد الصين
وفيها الكثير من المزاعم والادعاءات وبعد
ذلك يتوقع ان تكون العلاقات على خير ما
يرام ليست هذه الطريقه الصحيحه لكي يتصرف
الوزير ولكي يزور الصين شكرا لك ضيفي من
بيجين فيكتور جاو نائب رئيس مركز الصين
والعولمه واعتذر منك فقد ادركنا الوقت
كذلك الشكر لضيف من واشنطن بريان هاردينج
مستشار وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق
لشؤون امن اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
شهدت العاصمه النمساويه فيينا حفل تكريم
كبير للبروفيسور النمساوي من اصل سوري انس
شقفه مع على جهوده في دعم مسلم النمسا
ودمجهم في المجتمع وجاء تكريم بعد تبرئه
البروفيسور شقفه وعشرات الشخصيات
الاسلاميه من تهم الارهاب استنادا لوثائق
وادله حصريه عرضها تحقيق للجزيره في
برنامج ما خفي اعظم قبل عام ونصف العام
في مقر عمده العاصمه النمساويه فيينا اقيم
حفل تكريم خاص للبروفيسير النمساوي من اصل
سوري انس شقفه
هذا الرجل الذي تجاوز عمره 80 وراس الهيئه
الاسلاميه في النمسا سنوات طويله افعاله
وجهوده لا تخطئها عين عبر اجيال متلاحقه
شاهده على انجازات مسلمين واندماجهم في
النمسا ومحيطها اكثر من 800 شخصيه سياسيه
وبرلمانيه واكاديميه من وجوه المجتمع في
النمسا حضروا الحفل الذين نظمته بلديه
العاصمه بينهم الرئيس السابق للنمسا هاينز
فيشار
انس الشقفه الذي يكرم اليوم كان قبل عام
ونصف فمتهما بالارهاب من وجهه نظر الحكومه
النمساويه
ظهر الرجل ضمن برنامج الجزيره ما خفي اعظم
في تحقيقه الذي كشف بوثائق وادله حصريه
مسربه حمله ممنهجه ومنظمه قاده الحكومه
النمساويه برئاسه المستشار السابق
سيباستيان كورس لاتهام شخصيات ومؤسسات
اسلاميه بالارهاب وقد كان انس شقفه من
ابرز هذه الشخصيات
بفضل الوثائق والادله التي عرضها تحقيقها
خفي اعظم وبعد معركه قانونيه ضاريه تمت
تبرئه البروفيسور شقفه وعشرات اخرين
واسقاط تهم الارهاب بحقهم الحقيقه الجزيره
سلط الضوء على الملف بالكامل وانت تعرف
الموضوع يعني طال كثير من الاشخاص
واكثر هذه
التهم
حفظت ايضا لكن بامر محكمه واما في النسبه
لي شخصيا فلم تحلل المحكمه وانما المدعين
نفسه الذي بادر بالتهمه حفظ الملف وقال
انه لا فائده من الاستمرار في التحقيق
لانه لا توجد اي دلائل من بين حضور الحفل
الشاب الفلسطيني اسامه ابو الحسنى الذي تم
تكريمه سابقا لانقاذه شرطي النمساويا خلال
هجوم مسلح وقع في العاصمه فيينا كشف تحقيق
ما خفي اعظم ان اسامه كان احد ضحايا
الحمله وادرج اسمه ضمن قوائم الارهاب قبل
ان ينال البراءه اخيرا تغير بعض الاشياء
الايجابيه حصلت على
البرائح كما العليا ولكن للاسف
بحث هل كمان على
تم رفض من ناحيه الجنسيه النمساوي
وحاليا يعني المحاميه الخاصه هي يعني
شغاله بالموضوع وتعمل بالقوانين
الحكوميه هون اراد حفله تكريمي البروفيسور
انا الشقفان يعكس صوره تتجاوز الصدمه التي
تركتها عمليه الاقصر وهو الاسم الذي
اختارته الحكومه اليمينيه النمساويه
للعمليه التي داهمت السلطات فيها عشرات
المنازل والمؤسسات الاسلاميه الفاعله
عمليه تركت جدلا كبيرا وحادا في المجتمع
النمساوي وفرض التحديات جمه على مسلمها
حاضرا ومستقبلا
[موسيقى]
نعود الى ملف السودان حيث دخلت المواجهات
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع اسبوعها
الثامن ومع اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله
والخفيفه وتحليق لطائرات العسكريه كيف
تبدو خطوط المعركه
خطوط المعركه تدور في جنوب الخرطوم
وتحديدا في محيط مصنع اليرموك من
المستودعات الرئيسيه لمخازن الوقود والغاز
وهي من اكبر مستودعات المحروقات في
العاصمه السودانيه النيران ما زالت تشتعل
بكثافه هذه اللحظات في هذا المصنع منطقه
اليرموك الاستراتيجيه شهدت هجوما من طرف
قوات الدعم السريع حسب الجيش السوداني وهي
منطقه استراتيجيه يوجد بها مصنع اليرموك
للاسلحه وهو تابع لمنظومه الصناعات
الدفاعيه السودانيه نبقى دائما في العاصمه
الخرطوم حيث اشتدت المعارك ايضا في منطقه
جبرا والمناطق القريبه من حي ابو ادم الذي
يضم مقر ومنشات عسكريه مهمه كذلك ثم نتوجه
الان الى ام درمان غربي الخرطوم حيث حلقت
الطائرات العسكريه في سباق المدينه مع
سماع عدوي المدافع والانفجارات القويه
وتصاعد كثيف للسنه الذهبي والدخان مناطق
ام درمان وكذلك الخرطوم بحري وشرق النيل
من النقاط التي عرفت عنفا متزايدا خلال
الايام الماضيه والحديث في الساعات
الاخيره عن اشتباكات حول سلاح المهندسين
كما تعتبر ولايه دارفور ايضا من الساحات
الملتهبه طيله فتره الصراع حيث تحتدم فيها
المعارك مما يعرقل وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه ومع احتدام القتال في المدن
الثلاث التي تشكل العاصمه الكبرى الخرطوم
بحري وكذلك ام درمان تطرح اسئله عن تكلفه
اسابيع من المواجهات المسلحه وتداعيتها
الانسانيه
حياه الناس اليوميه تاثرت كثيرا بطبيعه
الحال فقد انهارت معظم الخدمات الصحيه كما
تنقطع امدادات الكهرباء والمياه كثيرا
وتنتشر اعمال النهب بشكل مرعب ويقول نشطاء
في الخرطوم بحري ان كثيرين نزحوا عن
ديارهم نتيجه انقطاع المياه المتكرر لاكثر
من 50 يوما ليجدوا انفسهم في مواجهه نيران
الحرب اثناء بحثهم عن المياه وطبعا تحت
ضغط المعارك نزح اكثر من مليون ونصف مليون
شخص من ديارهم داخل السودان وفق تقديرات
منظمات انسانيه بينما فر نحو نصف مليون
سوداني الى بلده الى بلدات المجاوره وايضا
بلدان مجاوره يعاني معظمها اصلا من الفقر
والصراعات الداخليه وفقا لتقديرات نشرتها
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره
وزاره الصحه السودانيه قدرت من جهتها مقتل
نحو 780 شخصا جراء العنف الدائر اضافه الى
اعداد اخرى لم تتمكن الجهات المختصه من
احصائها في دارفور غربي البلاد لمناقصه
الملف يحضر معنا في الاستوديو السيد
الدكتور مزمل ابو القاسم الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي السوداني اهلا بك دكتور مزمل في
هذه اللحظات النيره تتصاعد بشكل مخيف من
مصنع اليرموك مصنع اليرموك قريب من خزانات
استراتيجيه في الخرطوم بالنسبه للوقود اي
وضع نحن مقبلون عليه دكتور مزمل
لفهم طبيعه المعركه في الخرطوم يجب ان
نوضح حقيقه ان هناك سبعه مناطق عسكريه
اساسيه في الخرطوم ثلاثه ثلاثه منها في في
الخرطوم اتحدث عن الخرطوم العاصمه مثلثه
مكونه من ثلاثه مدن الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري
هناك ثلاثه
مراكز عسكريه اساسيه في الخرطوم هي
القياده العامه وسلاح المدرعات وقاعده
وادي سيدنا وقاعده جبل الاولياء جبل
اولياء العسكريه او قائد ومعها قاعده
النجومي الجويه في بحري هناك قاعده
اساسيتان الجيش هما سلاح الاشاره وفي في
منطقه بحر المركزيه وسلاح الاسلحه
والتدريب المهني
في ام درمان هناك مركزان اساسيان للجيش
هما سلاح المهندسين او منطقه ام درمان
العسك وقاعده وادي سيدنا الجويه المراكز
السبعه الاساسيه الوحدات العسكريه السبع
الاساسيه في العاصمه بيد الجيش وهي حصينه
جدا الشيء الذي دفع قوات الدعم السريع الى
تغيير تكتيكها للبحث عن وحدات عسكريه ذات
طبيعه فنيه غير قتاليه استهدفتها خلال
الفتره الماضيه هاجمت مجمع الصناعات
العسكريه او جهات في جنوب الخرطوم هاجمت
مصنع اليرموك اليوم
هاجمت قياده الدفاع الجوي في شارع 61
العمارات هذه الوحدات غير حصينه مثل
الوحدات العسكريه الاساسيه يعني هي وحدات
غير قتاليه فنيه مع الصناعيه او اداريه
والغرض منها تحقيق انتصارات ترفع الروح
المعنويه ولكن عندما يتعلق الامر بالمصنع
اليرموك نحن امام مكان استراتيجي بمصنع
اليرموك خارج نطاق الخدمه حاليا وانا لا
اقول انه مهم على اعتبار انه هذا هو
المصنع الاساسي الذي يمت القوات المسلحه
السودانيه
نعم وبالتالي لغوا اهميه كبيره ولكن هذا
المصنع خرج عن نطاق الخدمه وتوقف عن
الانتاج منذ بدايه هذه المعركه وحسب ما
علمت فان القوات المسلحه السودانيه قامت
بنقل معظم الزخائر الموجوده داخل المصنع
الى الوحده نقرا هذا المؤشر دكتور مزمل
هذه الاستراتيجيه توضح حقيقه العقيده
العسكريه لكل طرف الجيش السوداني بطبعه
عقيدته القتاليه الدفاعيه
منشاه في الاساس للدفاع عن حدود السودان
وعن اراضي البلاد وبالتالي هو لا يميل
الهجوم لو راينا منذ بدايه هذه المعركه
الجيش اكثر ميلا للدفاع عن مقراته من
المغامره بالهجوم بخلاف قوات الدعم
السريعه التي تعتمد عقي دتها القتاليه في
الاساس عن الهجوم هذا هو الفرق الجيش اتبع
استراتيجيه
تستهدف استنزاف قوه
الدعم السريع لاستنزاف زخائرها
الدكتور مزمل ابو القاسم الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي السوداني شكرا جزيلا اشكرك
[موسيقى]
يحدث في كندا الان حرائق الغابات في
مقاطعه البرتا تستمر في الانتشار رغم هطول
الامطار وانخفاض درجات الحراره تسببت هذه
الحرائق في تدمير اكثر من
375 الف هكتار من الاراضي في البرتا حتى
الان كما اضطر اكثر من 29 الف شخص الى
مغادره منازلهم وخرج نحو 31 حريقا عن
السيطره من اصل 108 من حرائق الغابات
النشطات التداعيات امتدت الى الولايات
المتحده المجاوره اكثر من 55 مليون شخص في
مناطق الشمال الشرقي ووسط الولايات
المتحده معرضون للهواء الملوث بسبب دخان
حرائق الغابات الناشئ من كندا
في الضفه الاخرى من المحيط اسبانيا تشهد
اكثر فصول الربيع حراره وثانيها جفافا منذ
بدء الاحتفاظ بالسجلات درجات الحراره عام
1961 عنوان الازمه يبقى كما هو فثمت تحذير
واضح يقول الخبراء ان تغير المناخ سيزيد
من وتيره وشده حرائق الغابات ويزيد الطقس
الحار والجاف نامل جميعا في عالم افضل
دمتم بخير والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]